Hello everybody!
Hello!
Hello, adventurer!
Morning!
Nice day for fishing!
Sorry, I had to.
If I'm playing this game, I have to say it.
I have to say the thing.
Apparently, a lot of people were very surprised.
I don't know how people are surprised about it because, you know, I've talked about Viva La Dirt League for... Oh, am I a bit loud?
Oh, I'm sorry.
Am I?
Oh, I got really close to the mic.
That's my bad.
I got a little too close to the mic.
I should be better now.
Uh, louder.
No, no, guys.
Um, we have one more day with the, uh, with the scuff mic and the scuff setup.
And then we will be free.
We will be free.
Um, um, but yes, I actually, like, really like, uh, I've always liked their videos.
I've been watching them for, like, um, I think I've been watching them for, like, a year now, I'm pretty sure.
Um, a year plus now.
Actually, no.
Around a year and a half, I think.
Uh, I've been watching them for a year and a half.
I know it's not been that long.
Um, but...
Um, I enjoy their content.
And, um, I was super excited that, uh, about their game.
That they've been, like, you know, teasing for a long time.
And, oh, recent fat.
Okay, a year and a half is still a long time.
It's not like I...
Actually, no.
I think it's two years.
It's two years.
I've, like, lost sense of time.
I think it's two years.
It's definitely been two years, um, since I've been watching them.
Um, but, yeah.
I was really looking forward to playing their game.
Um, um, I wasn't planning on playing their new game that soon.
But then, you know, since I'm traveling right now, um, I feel like, you know, this is a great time.
Because it is a pixel game.
And I know, like, these types of games tend to be not very intensive.
So, I'll be like, okay, this is, um, this would be, you know, the perfect game to play while I'm traveling.
So, um, um, yeah.
I love their series.
I love all their... I think the only ones I don't, I tend to don't watch is Tech Town.
I don't watch Tech Town, but, like, I watch all the other series.
Because, like, um, I can't relate to Tech Town.
I'm sorry.
Um, I don't mean like that, but, um, I never had to do...
I never worked at GameStop.
So, I can't really...
Um, uh, but, like, it's not gaming.
Of course you don't.
Uh, you know, they're talking about technology and stuff like that.
Uh, that's why I can't... I can't relate to real-life Tom's Chipotle there.
But I like all their other series.
I... I haven't... I didn't watch...
I only watched, like, one or two episodes from Tech Town.
But I watched the other series.
I, you know, I think everybody...
Everyone loves NPC... The Adventures of NPC Man.
I think that one was... I think that one and the one where they...
Parody Blizzard HQ.
I... I enjoyed both.
Those were... Those two are my favorite series so far.
Um, I like that one.
I like, you know, The Adventures of Epic NPC Man.
And also the, uh, the Blizzard parody one is really good.
Uh...
Um, uh, so I like those two.
The D&D one was good, too.
I like the D&D one.
Even though I don't play Dungeons... I don't really play Dungeons and Dragons.
The D&D one was... Is really good.
I like anything Rowan... Rowan...
I love Rowan as a character because he always plays, like, the...
The dumb... The dumb doofus guy.
So...
So I can relate to him.
Uh...
Um...
But yeah, I figured this is a good one-off game to play while I'm traveling.
And, um...
Super excited to try it out.
They've been, like, teasing it for a long time.
I still can't believe yesterday my, uh, the internet died.
I...
I couldn't... Like, what are the chances?
I was actually...
We were all so happy yesterday when we finally got Delta Rune to run.
And then, like, the mo... I didn't even get to character creation.
I literally didn't even get to character creation mode.
And then the internet died.
And then it came back, like, uh...
I think it came back on, like, 15 minutes later.
And I was like, I... I'm whatever.
It's just like...
I was like, I can't believe it.
Like, the game...
Delta Rune really didn't want me to play it today.
Or yesterday.
The game really didn't want me to play.
You must.
And then the internet went out.
I was like, alright.
Fuck it.
I have played it.
I get to head to bed early, I guess.
Um...
Now, today's been a long day.
But it's nice.
We get to relax.
Um...
We get to relax with some fishing.
I forgot mostly about the lore of this...
Oh, hey.
It's a nice day for fishing.
Ha-ha.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
No, the internet actually died.
And then I ended stream because the internet died.
Welcome to the world of Azrim.
A harsh world of magic.
Monsters, heroes, and adventures.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
This is Balin, the fisherman.
He's one of the many NPCs of the town of Honeywood.
Let's follow Balin and meet some of the other Honeywood NPCs.
Alright.
Welcome to Honeywood.
A simple town in Azrim where players start their journeys as adventurers.
Along with all the brave adventurers, Honeywood is also inhabited by his very own town's folks, the NPCs.
Willing to sell sword.
Take Greg, the garlic.
Oh my god, it's Greg!
The garlic farmer.
For example, he is the main quest giver of Honeywood.
Which is actually kind of weird because he's literally just a garlic farmer.
And honestly, he gets way too much attention.
I know, he's just there.
Welcome to the town.
There's a...
Oh!
It's the skip guy!
That's me as here.
This is why I don't play.
Oh my god, it's my man, Greg.
Well, that was rude.
While guest heroes have much more important things to do than hear about my problems.
Morning.
Hey, Balin.
Nice day for fishing, ain't it?
It sure is, Balin.
I think this is more so, like, people who watch their videos.
Like, because there's so many, like, inside jokes from their videos.
And there's Bulger, the blacksmith.
How else would adventurers get...
Oh my god, this is the one time you see Balin and Bulger together in the same...
In the same room.
Because it's pixel art.
The blacksmith.
How else would adventurers get the finest weapons and armor needed to face the many dangers of Azerim.
The reason why I say that is because they're both played by the same actor.
See, it's the same guy.
It's literally the same guy.
You handsome W.
The U.
Yeah, just like every other time you mention it.
Alright, what's this?
Oh, it's the guy.
It's that guy.
The main guy.
The hero.
Once adventurers have done enough crappy low-level quests, they get to meet me.
Hi, Sorcerer Baradun.
I start them on the main campaign, where they're trying to become the hero of Azerim.
Ha-ha!
Alright, look at me for...
Morning.
The world needs you, adventurer.
Greetings, Balin.
I'm currently working on a heroic story about my heroic deeds.
It's very heroic.
Here, let me show you something.
That's a bit efficient, ain't it?
Yes, Balin.
Behold, the chest of abandoned souls.
It's a very dangerous relic.
Only a mighty sorcerer like me can handle it.
Let me tell you the story about this relic.
Who you...
Did you know they took...
I know, right?
They took Adam's likeness for this.
Oh my god.
Hey, Bernard, lift me higher.
Do you see that sorcerer guy with the shiny thingy?
Yeah, Charles.
It sounds really expensive.
Let's go mug him.
Okay, if people look very similar, um...
In the show, in the YouTube videos, there's only six actors.
Wait, no.
Five.
There's only five actors.
And they all...
They all populate the town.
This town.
So, Bernard is also the same actor.
That's the third Rowan.
It's also the same actor, um, as the other two guys.
So, like, my favorite is that it's, like, it's, like, they do this thing where it's, like, the Amy, the Amy thing.
The token Amy.
So, like, the...
Okay, sometimes they have two female actresses.
But then it's usually just one female actress in the...
In the acting group.
So, it's, like, four guys and one female actress.
Sometimes...
Sometimes there's two.
Five guys and they're...
Four guys and they're clones.
Bernard, he said it's really dangerous.
Oh, yeah.
I heard that.
Really dangerous.
Let's go mug him.
Bernard, he said only a sorcerer can handle it.
Hey, what are we?
Oh, well, we're...
We're muggers.
Yeah?
And what do muggers do?
Well, they mug people.
So, let's go mug him.
Oh, my God.
He's mugging him.
What have you done?
You fools.
Nobody was supposed to touch this.
Wait, what have we done, Bernard?
Let's get out of here.
Oh, my God.
They're mugging.
Wait.
What is this?
There's something inside the chest.
It looks like some kind of ancient scroll.
Written by the creators of the world.
Oh, this is really bad.
Oh, wait.
I just remembered.
I left that oven on.
Portal away.
Goodbye.
Oh, connection lost.
Oh, my God.
The real players.
We destroyed the server.
Wait.
Who's going to save Honeywood?
I'm here.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to be the adventurer now.
The server is dying.
Oh, I'm a player.
Hello.
I'm Balin.
Morning.
Nice day for fishing.
Are you okay, Balin?
You look kind of different.
Greg, what on earth did you do?
You seem kind of heroic.
Almost like an adventurer.
Speaking of which, have you seen any of them around?
They all seem to be gone.
Why are all the adventurers gone again?
Did you do something, Greg?
Well, at least we have some peace and quiet for now.
Hey, Balin.
Come here for a sec.
I'm sure it's your fault.
Balin, did you hear me?
Come here for a sec.
Okay, now I can walk.
Morning.
Wait, I can't go here?
It's not fair.
Alright.
You notice how quiet it is today?
I'm sure some adventurers are on the help of my quest.
I need someone to collect three garlics for me.
Did you just accept my quest?
How is that possible?
Do I just say morning?
Look at that garlic film.
I made them sparkle so that even the dumbest adventurer knows how that they have to collect them.
Okay.
So help Greg collect some garlic.
Alright, here you go, Greg.
I got you the garlic.
How are you able to do my quest?
This is incredible!
Normally, only mighty adventurers can do them.
Guys, I watched too much Viva La Dirt.
I know exactly, like, you could tell that I have, I got there, like, like, the way they talk, the intonations of how they talk down because I watched too much.
Speaking of adventurers, where have they all gone?
This is getting weird.
Ah, well, I'm sure there's nothing to worry about.
On the bright side, I guess this means we have some spare time, right?
Hmm.
Since there's no adventurers around, I wonder if you could help me with something.
I need some fish for dinner, and you're obviously the perfect man for the job.
By the way, here's a small reward for you.
Yay!
He gave me the three garlic that I gave him.
Okay, I can't go that way yet.
No fish yet?
Oh, I have to use the garlic as bait?
Okay.
Can I steal more?
Okay, I can steal more of his garlic.
Nice.
You don't need it.
Your whole job is to farm.
Okay.
All right, now I can finally play my fishing game.
You can move the hook up and down.
Okay.
All right.
So, I just do that.
Oh, I can't move it too far.
Okay.
Come on.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Oh, I attack by...
I attack by fishing.
All right.
The weakest fish in Honeywood.
Even the lowliest adventurers have caught this fish at some point.
Yay!
A fish caught.
Finally.
A game for me.
All right.
I think it doesn't go too low.
So, I'm gonna catch this fish too.
Okay.
How many...
How many did Greg want?
I already forgot how many he wanted.
Greg, how many did you want?
One, thank you for the garlic, Greg.
There you go.
Hello, adventurer.
Great catch, Balan.
Thank you for the fish.
Well, with no adventurers around, I can't give out any quests.
I guess I'm just gonna take it easy today.
Maybe you can use the free time to upgrade your fishing rod.
A longer fishing line will help you catch better fish.
Look, I skipped dialogue.
Just like the other adventurers.
Ask Boger the blacksmith.
He's a pretty bad blacksmith, but he always has a ton of crap laying around.
I'm sure he can make a longer line for you.
And here, take some more garlic as a reward for the fish.
I have plenty.
Okay, I can literally steal his garlic right here.
I'll need you to give me garlic, Greg.
Skip.
Hey, Balan.
My friend, how can good old Boger help you?
Ah, it looks like your fishing rod needs an upgrade.
It's just a bent stick with a ball of shooting attached.
It's a miracle you can catch anything with this.
Well, you're in luck.
I have a better fishing line I can spare.
But first, you have to do me a favor.
That's how being an adventurer goes, I'm afraid.
Gotta do a quest for me.
I was out getting supplies, and when I returned, I noticed that my grandfather's hammer was missing.
Can you help me find it?
An adventurer told me it's in the town well to the east.
But I can't leave my smithy unattended.
If you bring me my hammer, then the new fishing line is all yours.
Alright, I gotta open my map.
Alright, where is it?
It's like right there.
It's not that far.
I don't know.
Do you want to find my fish?
Oh my god, it's Fred!
Doki put so much work in his dialogue, practiced it again and again, and you're gonna skip it?
That's so- I didn't skip it!
I actually paid attention!
Bala would never.
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Feel free to browse my rice.
Oh, I guess I can afford to buy things from you if I sell one of my children first.
Alright, buy my fish.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Oh, hey!
It's Eugene!
Oh!
Oh, it's this guy!
I need- I need a brain bureau to help me, but there are no adventures nearby!
Oh, it's the- Oh, it's this guy!
I know him.
I like how it's just all, like, inside jokes.
Please do not fish this side, Mr. Oh, okay.
I'm gonna fish in the well.
Oh, it's a hammer!
Nice.
Cry.
W.A.B.
Skip-a-skip-a.
I wonder if there's an Easter egg if I just keep skipping him.
Oh, hello, Balan.
Alright.
Hey, you found my grandfather's hammer!
You have no idea how much this means to me.
Let me tell you a little story.
This hammer- Skip, skip.
Alright.
It's finished.
Why don't you give the new line a try?
Oh, nice!
Oh, I got the Honeywood line.
Alright, skipping that was okay.
The world needs you, adventurer.
I, High Sorcerer, Baradin, have come from the Temple of Calibor to send you a message and...
Wait, Balan?
I thought you were an adventurer.
Huh.
That's so weird.
Why did I think you were an adventurer?
Speaking of which, where did they all go?
Yeah, I need the bucket, guys.
Normally, I would now explain the main quest and go on an epic journey with an adventurer.
Not a lowly, peasant fisherman.
No offense.
Hmm, you know what?
Maybe you can be useful after all.
You see, there's a mysterious fish at the bottom of the Honeywood pond that I've always wanted to examine.
Normally, I would give an adventurer this quest, but since there aren't any adventurers around, maybe you can catch the mysterious fish.
So what do you say?
Could you do me a favor and catch a fish?
Huh-huh.
Morning.
Nice day for fishing.
Alright.
Okay, I did not want the fucking Honeywood Aaron to try and catch this one.
Okay, I need him out of here.
Alright.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, yeah!
Level up!
Nice!
Wait, am I gonna have to fight?
Wait, this is a fishing game.
What do you mean fight?
Oh my god.
Get out!
I...
Get out of here!
Okay.
Okay, this...
This tap.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
That's much better.
Alright.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
I thought I'm fishing.
What do I need defense for?
Are they gonna fight back?
Whoa!
What the...
Guys, they fought back.
They...
Yes, apparently.
Apparently.
Okay.
How the fuck was that?
Ow.
Oh my god.
Wait, how do I...
Do I not fight him when he does that?
Okay.
Wait.
They did.
Fought back.
Okay, I have an idea.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
That's...
Oh, oh, okay.
Okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Yay!
But we all know she skips and she can't read.
I still love my alert.
Oh, she...
Not so dead, but thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Warren, thank you for the super chat.
Dookie, in order to save the world, you must skip a skip up.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, I skipped too much, guys.
Guys, all it took was you to read.
I'm sorry, I was skipping the dialogue.
Alright.
Nice.
Yoink, my garlic.
Wow, that is an ugly fish.
It makes sense since it came from this ugly shithole of a town.
But this fish is no orderling fish.
There seems there's something trapped inside of it.
Some kind of evil?
I wonder what would happen if I'd use a spell on it.
I don't think you should... Oops.
What happened?
Oh.
Wait, what the fuck?
It's Squidman.
I am the Dark Lord, he's howling.
I am darkness and conrad.
I am the lord of the depths of the sea.
Who dares to awaken me?
I was sealed at the bottom of this foul pond for thousands of years.
But I am finally free once more.
Behold my powers!
For I will destroy this pitiful village right before I conquer all of Azerim.
Bro, I was just trying to fish, bro.
Oh no!
Adventurer!
You must save Honeywood!
Um... Adventurers?
Huh?
What's that?
No adventurer attacking me?
Well, yeah.
Normally the adventurers will fight you now and save the village, I guess.
But, they're all gone.
We just have Balin, the fisherman.
Hmm...
Okay, but Balin is surprisingly incredibly strong though.
And you piss him off.
Well, in that case...
This is my chance to conquer Azerim for good!
Mwahaha!
Balin, quick!
Use your new adventurer powers!
Let me challenge you to a fishing contest!
What are you doing?
I'm trying to fish, bro!
Enough of this!
You are far too weak to stop me!
Now witness my power!
Can I, like, romance him?
Like...
Uh, like that other...
Hahahaha!
And as promised, I will destroy this puny village!
What?
You can do it in the other game?
Why can't I do it in this game?
Hahahaha!
Balin?
Balin, are you awake?
Oh no!
The town of Honeywood!
Okay, but, like, this town is a shithole, so like...
It's not like we lost anything.
It's literally level one village.
The town is destroyed, and there's still no sound of any ventures out!
Baradun fought the evil sea monster guy in an epic battle!
Unfortunately, you were unconscious, so you didn't witness it.
Man, it was so epic!
Also, this is a long-ass server maintenance.
Doki-do!
It's an iconic landmark!
After destroying our village, the creature escaped with Baradun hot on his tail!
It was such an incredible fight!
Spells, evil magic, fireballs!
You really missed an incredible show!
Pity you were in a fade to black!
Honeywood is in ruins!
Please, search for survivors, Balin!
I'll stay here!
Alright, let me steal some...
Balin, now is not the time for fishing!
But it's always time for fishing!
Okay, I'm still gonna steal your garlic.
Greg...
I can't believe he would say that!
It's always time for fishing!
Every day is a nice day to fish!
Please help me, Balin!
I've been badly injured!
Talk to Greg!
He'll know what to do!
Alright...
Oh, hello, Balin!
Oh, you found Frey?
Poor guy looks injured!
This extra strong garlic will help him get him back on his feet!
Please!
Give it to him!
Alright, here's the garlic!
Hello!
Oh, you're back?
Did Greg have anything to help me?
Whoa!
This garlic is so strong!
I feel much better!
Thanks for your help, Balin!
Okay, I just realized, guys...
Okay...
I need to...
My phone was never charged.
Is it charged now?
Ha!
Okay, I think...
I assume it'll be charged...
It'll be awkward if it isn't.
Uh...
Sadly, all my stuff is destroyed!
I have to start my business from scratch again!
Maybe you can help me!
If you bring me some fish, I'll buy them from you!
By the way, I saw a booger searching for something at the well!
You sure could talk to him!
Oh, nice!
Wait, I got a friend!
Is he gonna follow me?
Wait, what?
Hahaha!
How do you got a person as a reward?
Alright, I'll sell another fish.
Ooh, wait!
This fish is better than the other fish.
Okay, it's one dollar.
I'm not giving you my fish, friend.
Someone else would appreciate my fish.
Oh, wait, is there something here?
Hey, Balin!
Hey!
Did you see that horrible sea creature?
The beacons of Miramar have been lit, but no adventurers are coming to our aid.
Hey!
Why do you sound more feminine when forcing men?
What do you mean?
Let me double check my phone real quick.
Okay, it says it's charging, but I don't know why.
It's like, it's like on and off.
Alright.
Hahaha!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Honey, where did my shop have been destroyed?
During the chaos of destruction, my grandfather's hammer was blasted away.
Can you help me find it?
Okay, but that's just Greg, guys.
That's not me.
That's just Greg.
Guys, Greg sounds like that.
Okay.
For the peace of the ca- Oh, hey, that's me again!
Wait, no, is that- No, that's not me.
That's the other guy.
The blonde guy.
Alright.
Can I jump?
I can't- I don't know how to jump yet.
Where's your hammer?
Oh, it's back- Wait, where is your hammer?
I don't know where the fuck your- Oh, wait.
I don't know where the fuck your hammer is.
Is it back in here?
Oh my god, it's back in here.
Okay, here you go.
Here you go, booger.
My grandfather's hammer!
What would I do without it?
Oh, so Meep, thank you for 10 gifted ships!
Thank you, thank you!
It's- Is that also Rowan?
There's so many Rowans.
I- What would I do without it?
But did you know this hammer is rightfully mine?
It was given to me rightfully by my grandfather.
This hammer has been in my family for generations, and is rightfully mine.
I vowed to never lose it ever again.
But for now, we need a plan.
We should talk to Greg.
Let's go!
Nice!
I got a- Nice, I have- I have booger.
Nice.
Alright, Greg.
I got them all back.
Hello, adventurer!
You found a booger?
I was a little worried, but don't tell him that.
Anyway, honey, we sure could use your help, Balen.
Everyone looks pretty bad beat up.
You can catch some fish to feed people.
I'm sure everyone will be very grateful.
Okay, I just need one more fish.
Finally!
The real game.
Yoink my garlic.
Alright, finally, I can actually play my favorite part of this game.
Fishing!
Alright.
Hello, fishies.
Hello!
Okay, so when they turn around, I just need to make sure I don't do anything.
Yay!
Alright.
I level up!
Alright, nice.
It's such a nice day for fishing, guys.
Hey!
You caught some fish!
With everything destroyed, this fish will help keep people fed.
You saved our lives, Balen!
It's a small reward.
The town's folks put together say thanks.
Now we can plan our next step.
Talk to me when you're ready.
Oh, nice.
I have five gold coins.
A whole five gold coins.
Let's go.
Yoink my garlic.
Hey, Balen.
I've been thinking about the evil fish monster thing that destroyed Honeywood.
If only no more, we probably need to speak with High Sorcerer Baroden.
Ugh.
Baroden followed that creature across the lake.
We need to get you over there.
But how?
How are you gonna feed- Okay, they have three- This village has three people.
I think the crying guy died.
So like, that's alright.
One less mouth to feed.
So three people, three fishes.
Hmm.
If I have enough supplies, I could probably craft a boat for you.
If you bring me five bits of scrap wood, that should be enough to craft a boat.
Come back with the scrap wood and we can plan our next step.
I mean, what happened to cry.wav guy?
Oh, nice.
I got scrap wood.
Oh, okay.
This is scrap wood.
Okay.
It's just lying there.
It's part of the destroyed village.
Uh, what about- Okay, but like, he's not part of the village though.
He's just there.
No, not him.
That's Fred.
The crying guy used to be here, but I think he's dead now.
I- Hahaha!
Fuck!
That should be enough.
Fred and I also found some fabric for the sale.
Give this a boat and finish the crafting.
Yeah, that's enough supplies.
Now, to build a boat.
No more- Yeah, Eugene's dead, I'm pretty sure.
Rest in peace Eugene, I think.
It's finished.
A true masterpiece of craftsmanship.
You can thank me and my good ol' hammer.
Which is rightfully mine.
No more crying.
W-A-B.
The boat is ready for you, Balan.
Search for Baranun.
To the west.
Meanwhile, we'll continue our work here in Honeywood.
Good luck!
Nice!
I got a boat.
Okay.
And let me pick up some more garlic.
Yoink.
Alright.
Here I'll go.
On my boat- Oh, wait!
I must be able to fish the chest, right?
Okay, I need to...
Go back a little.
Okay.
Oh, I have to like gauge the distance for this.
Wait, what?
Okay, let me just beat up this bass then.
Don't you dare look away.
Oh, oh!
Oh!
Okay.
Come on, look at me!
Look at me!
Alright, nice.
Alright.
I wanna fish this chest.
Come on.
Okay, I need to be a bit closer.
Oh, I can't.
Okay, I can't pick it up.
Aww.
Yeah, this is based on the YouTube series.
They made a new game.
Wait, did I caught this before?
No, he's big.
He's a big boy!
Ooh!
Oh, wait.
Attacking the enemy raises his rage, charging up its spell.
Oh, shit.
Okay, he's angry.
Don't worry.
Okay.
It's not...
It's just 5 HP.
That's 5.
Alright.
Don't be angry.
Come on!
Oh!
Oh, never mind.
Okay.
I'm too weak for this fish.
I know, right?
What the fuck did fish in as we're able to do magic?
I wonder if I can grab that chest, though.
Wait.
This fish looks scary.
Oh, I can't.
Wait, what?
Oh, he hates that.
He's a picky fish.
Couple less chests.
Okay.
I need to be a little bit further away.
Alright, here we go.
Yeah, he's a picky eater.
I can't believe he doesn't like garlic!
This is from the finest...
The finest garlic in all of Honeywood.
The shit village.
Okay, the common carp.
If I know anything about carp in Animal Crossing, is that this is a shitty fish.
Okay.
Come on.
Oh my god, he does so much damage.
Are you serious?!
8 HP?!
Oh...
Oh my god.
Okay, he's dead.
Okay, never mind.
I don't think I'm strong enough for him.
I have to do a base.
A bass fish.
What was the Animal Crossing saying when you catch a bass fish?
Come on.
Eat my...
Eat this.
He just died.
He like actually just disappeared.
Oh!
Wait, I don't think I can block.
Yeah, I can't block guys.
I don't have that ability yet.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Oh!
I have a big guy.
Alright.
Hello.
I have five dollars.
Hello, Baradun.
Fisherman.
Baradun, what brings you over the side of the lake?
You missed my epic fight with the evil fish monster guy.
What was his name again?
Ah, the dark lord is Halden.
I was so badass.
But due to the budget cuts, you just couldn't see it because we can't afford the CGI.
But just as I was winning, he managed to escape and now my mana is depleted.
Maybe he can help me by catching a fresh fish.
I heard the basic bass are delicious.
This is also the perfect opportunity to train blocking.
Oh, now I can block.
Simply hold B to block enemy attacks.
Can you catch some bass for me?
And try to block the attacks a few times.
Okay, now I can block guys.
I learned how to block.
Okay, where's the bass fish area?
Okay.
And then...
I'm blocking.
Okay.
Oh, I have to hold it.
Okay, I'm clearly... I don't...
I was trying to perfect parry it.
There we go.
I was trying to perfect parry it for some fucking reason.
I was trying to be so smart.
Oh, no.
No, no, no, no, no!
He was one!
I'm so sad.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I can swim over here.
Come on.
Eat this.
Eat this garlic.
Okay, now I know.
I know now, guys.
Okay.
I know now.
You can't perfect parry.
Oh, wait!
That's not a bass!
Whoops!
Whoops.
Okay, I never got catch a...
I already have a bass though.
Okay, but I'm catching them in advance, guys.
I'm catching him in advance.
Nice.
Alright.
I already...
Okay, I need one more...
The orange guy right here.
Okay, I fucked up.
I forgot to have range.
Okay, here you go.
Nice.
Okay, I feel like I don't need to...
I don't need to block this guy.
He doesn't do that much damage.
Look at him.
He's so fucking weak.
Okay.
Come on.
Get over here.
Yay!
Ooh!
Another new record.
Nice.
Alright.
Time to talk to Baradun.
Hello, Baradun.
Don't pour it away yet.
I'm here.
Ah, good work, Baradun.
I guess I'll give you a small reward.
I am, after all, very generous and handsome.
Yay!
More money!
Hmm.
Something is strange about this fish.
Looks like that evil fish guy had an influence on the fish.
We must investigate this more.
Bring me some freshly caught carbon carp next.
This is also perfect for training you and parrying.
Hold...
Be right before an enemy attacks.
Support form a perfect block.
Okay, there you go.
See, I told you.
Alright, so there is perfect parrying.
Okay.
How the fuck do you do perfect parry?
I do it right before he does the thing.
Okay.
Alright.
Just before the enemy hits.
Okay.
Okay, did I do it?
Oh my god.
Wait, did I do it?
I can't tell!
Did I- I can't tell!
Did I...
Did I do it?
Okay.
Oh yeah!
Okay, it shows up.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
It's like...
It's like noob friendly.
That's good.
That's me.
Okay.
Oh my god, I don't know if I did it right.
Yes!
Okay, I think that was it!
Wait, was it?
Okay, I think that was it.
Oh, oh.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
No!
No.
I can't tell if I'm doing it correctly.
Okay.
Wait.
This is it.
I figured it out.
Okay.
I don't think I did it.
I... I don't think I did it!
Oh my god, it's so... Okay.
Okay.
That... I don't know.
I don't... I can't... I don't know.
Parry... Okay, guys.
I don't think we're perfect parrying, guys.
Just like in all the other Souls games, I don't think we can perfect parry.
Great job.
Now let me examine the fish and a small reward as we do for a quest well done.
Yay!
Tank one!
This is terrible.
This looks like the deeper the fish live, the stronger the dark powers are.
There was a type of fish called a snakefish in the snake.
It was a very hard fish to catch before.
I'm sure it's now nearly impossible to catch one.
But I have to be sure.
Let me teach you this spell so you can defeat the snakefish.
With this spell, you can repair your fishing rod, but it will cost you stamina.
This really is a feeling a lot.
Like I'm a lowly tutorial NPC now.
Affiliate, I'm thinking for the five gifted ships.
Thank you.
I did.
I pressed the V, but I feel like it doesn't react in time.
Simply use to cast the spell, and this is how the sorcerers do it.
Also, thank you for that raid on me.
Thank you.
We just... and yes, we just pressed... Now hurry up and catch that fish.
All right.
Okay, so that's how you do a fast repair.
Okay.
Where is that snakefish again?
It's like all the way down here.
Oh, there he is.
Oh my god.
Wait, there's so many.
Oh!
Wait, there's more down here.
Okay.
Okay, I... oh shit.
Feel yourself.
Whoops.
Okay.
I don't know how I can...
Oh!
Oh shit!
Oh fuck!
Oh my god.
That's perfect.
That's a perfect parry.
Okay, I did it.
Here I see it from his nimble body.
How cunning this fish is.
Many beginning anglish fish...
Okay, I did it, guys.
I did it.
They got hands.
I don't know how I did it, but I did it.
I knew that spell will help you catch the fish.
Man, I'm such a good sorcerer.
I really am the best.
Wait, he's alive!
I heard some pathetic crying from the west.
It must be one of the villagers.
But the way is blocked by a rock.
A few weeks ago, I ordered a chest with magic goods.
But it never arrived at Honeywood.
And one of the chests was a mystic scrawl.
But I think the chest got lost in the lake.
Can't use this magnetic hook and recover the chest.
Just attach it to your fishing rod.
Hurry!
I really hope this tutorial will be over soon.
Okay, by using...
Oh, okay.
Alright.
So I just need to change my hook to this.
And then I can have the magnetic chest.
Yay!
Okay, that's too...
Okay, my only issue is that it doesn't tell you how much I need to do for this.
Oh, wait.
I'm gonna use...
I'm gonna yoink.
It's cry.wav.
No!
Eugene lived!
Who let him live?
Okay, it's like all the way here.
I'm just trying to remember where it was.
It's like here.
Okay, I just need to move...
A little bit.
Alright.
Nice!
Okay, what's in here?
Wait, what did I catch?
Uh...
Ancient rod.
Oh!
Wait, I won't use that.
From a time...
The ancestors' remnants...
Or maybe that's just tinnitus.
Okay, nice.
Okay, that's plus 15 strength.
I got the ancient rod.
I got a new fishing rod.
You gotta actually, like, know where it is.
Alright.
Nice!
More money!
Alright.
Time to give...
Better than his fucking squirrel.
Alright.
Sorry.
Tetanus.
Yeah.
Yes, this is the squirrel.
Thank you, Balin.
Now, I will give you a demonstration of my glorious power.
Stand back!
Unlimited power!
Yay!
There.
Now the path is unblocked.
You're welcome.
Do you know any other tutorial NPCs who can do that?
Okay, nice.
I got five gold.
Adventure, please!
I need your aid!
You have to help me!
Careful.
This creature is dangerous.
Looks like it captured that poor villager.
Me hungry.
Me eat human.
By the gods!
It can talk!
I don't want to be eaten.
Please help me!
We have to stop.
What the fuck do I do?
All I do is fish!
I could easily save him a simple spell if I wanted.
But I have to save my magic for facing greater evils.
So, you know what?
This looks like a perfect quest for you, Bailey!
What the fuck do I do?
I'm just a fisherman!
Yoink!
Me want fish!
I will eat crybaby human!
You smell like fish!
Tasty!
Bring me blue fish!
Bring me and other human will be free!
Oh, okay.
Nice.
He wants a very trolling trout?
That fish lives in the desert of the lake!
It is known for his blue color and defensive behavior.
I don't think your line is long enough to reshare.
You should go back to Honeywood.
Maybe somebody has a longer line.
Okay, so I just need to...
Okay, I was gonna say, like...
I don't think I've seen that fish before.
Alright.
Goodbye.
Goodbye, everybody.
I'm gonna get a longer fishing ride.
I was like, what the fuck do you want me to do?
I'm just a fisherman.
How do I fight people when all I do is fish?
Yoink.
Alright.
Nice.
Thanks for the guide.
Ah, Balin, you're back.
You need a longer line?
You're in luck.
I happen to have a spare.
However, I'm a bit distracted in a moment.
My...
Okay.
Without the hammer, I'm not able to do anything.
Find it for me.
Alright.
Guys, I wonder where that new hammer...
Where his hammer is.
Let's try and see if it's down here.
Whoa, there it is.
Alright.
Where ever could it be?
Hey, Balin.
My grandfather's hammer.
Where did you find it?
Thank you for retrieving it.
The wrapper with this hammer was rightfully given to me by my grandfather on his deathbed.
I don't know what I would do without it.
I vowed never to lose this hammer again.
Oh, and here's the longer line for you.
Thank you, Balin.
By the way, I can sell you stuff now.
You can earn gold by selling fish to Fred.
Oh, wait.
What does he sell?
Advanced rod, essential rod, pro rod.
Okay, I can almost get that.
Oh.
I see you got a longer line.
So now your next step is to catch the special fish for that pesky goblin, right?
Do you understand what you're trying to reel in?
This fish might be peaceful and weak, but it's heavily armored.
You'll never pull out while you're just a flimsy fishing rod.
Luckily, I know a spell which could be useful.
The first spell I show you affects you, but this one affects your enemy.
You'll do a lot of damage in exchange for stamina.
You can cast a spell by using down to attack your target.
Man, you're really lucky to have such a powerful sorcerer teaching you things.
I am really the best.
Alright, I have so much garlic now.
Alright, I find the blue fish.
I still don't know how to properly do the perfect parry.
There's like a slight delay.
I noticed when I try to do it.
Oh, there he is.
Okay, I just need him to swim over.
Hello, please swim over.
Okay, I'm just...
Did he just swim over by then?
I think he has a long way to...
Yeah, no, I'm just gonna go back.
I think he has a long way until he gets to me.
Alright.
Oh, wait, he doesn't like garlic.
I forgot.
Oh, there we go.
Alright, get over here.
Alright.
Damage spell!
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I wasn't reading.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
Reading is for losers.
Okay.
Yay!
This guy is being really shy.
We did it.
Yay.
You got this.
Yay!
Reading!
Okay, I wanna catch one more...
One more of these.
I need practice fishing.
I actually...
Okay.
Okay, this is very convenient, though.
This spell is really good.
Okay.
Blocking.
Nice.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
He doesn't have to...
He doesn't teach you how to block anymore.
He doesn't teach you how to parry.
They're already sending me out into the ocean.
Alright, here we go.
They look like the guys who...
Oh, it is the same guys.
No, it is the same guys.
These are the guys that made all these sketches for PUBG back then.
Me smell of tasty fish.
Give to me a me free human.
Thank you, Baylen.
Can you please escort me back to Honeywood?
Alright, let's...
He didn't blow up.
Oh, wait.
He also buys fish.
Look at that.
Me want fish.
Alright, my price...
Oh, wait!
He gives me four?
Oh, wait.
No.
Actually, that's not good.
Is this Deltarune?
I went to sleep yesterday while you were trying to get it to work.
Yes, this is Deltarune.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait.
No.
Something's not right.
What's this?
Yeah, chapter three is a fishing video game.
By the gods!
It's...
Threwed off the fears!
Nobody has seen this foul water dragon in ages.
Much less near-beloved Honeywood.
It's going to kill us.
Adventurers call this one a boss.
It has a different combat style than fish who've caught before.
There's no pull and relax space.
Just hit that fiend really hard and fast and block incoming attacks in the right moments.
I beg you please, defeat the monstrous creatures or I will never see Honeywood and my wife again.
Rike.
I won.
Whoops.
Wait.
What?
But when would an attack?
How would I know...
Oh.
Oh my God.
Okay, watch this.
Boom!
Okay, there we go.
Okay, I figured it out.
Oh my god, okay, never mind.
Clearly I didn't figure it out.
Clearly... clearly... clearly... oh my god.
Clearly I didn't.
Got it.
I have time to do this.
Okay, nice.
I think if I know how to perfect parry, it would look cooler.
It would look so much cooler.
It is...
Oh, oh!
Oh, I did it!
Okay, I figured it out.
I think I figured it out.
Okay, watch.
Oh my god.
Oh, Dragon Rage.
Okay.
Okay, I think I definitely figured it out.
Oh my god, it does look so much cooler.
Okay.
Oh no.
I can't keep doing it though.
Oh!
Wait, my phone died!
No!
My phone died, please!
Please!
No!
It's not fair!
Oh, okay, there we go.
Everything's fine.
What time?
Okay.
Okay, I realized what is wrong, guys.
I forgot to charge my phone when I was going... when I was out.
So...
So it's like absorbing it more...
I'm using up more of the battery...
...than...
...than it's charging.
I'm not charging it fast enough...
...for the use of it.
You...
You did it!
What a fight!
Seems like it trapped a magical ring.
You should go to your inventory and equip it like adventurers do.
Let's hurry back now.
I'm sure my wife isn't in great danger right now.
But you never know with these questlines.
No, I just have a weak charger.
Right now.
Okay, let's equip this.
Wait, where is it?
Where's my ring?
Oh, there it is.
Move cursors.
To equip with IMA.
Okay.
Timing.
Oh, wait, there you go.
Shows timing.
Okay, I need that.
Okay, wait.
Give me a sec.
Sorry.
Every...
It's been...
It's been a very scuffed day.
Alright, let's see if this works, guys.
Let's...
Let's see...
Let's see if this works.
I'm risking it.
Alright.
Okay.
Let's put it on.
I'm risking it.
There you go.
Maybe now.
I can save...
I can save battery.
Alright.
Alright, don't worry.
Today's the last day.
Today.
My soul is back.
Don't worry.
My soul is now back.
Alright.
Hello.
Okay.
We gotta give him...
Take him back to his home.
Alright.
Go home.
Thank you for bringing me home.
Thank you for bringing me home, Balen.
I was always remembering your act of kindness.
It seems like Greg wants to talk to you.
Uh-huh.
That man is cry.wav, and you're laughing.
By the way, while you've been busy fighting dragons, I've been restocking my goods.
Which I can trade.
Talk to me anytime if you want useful stuff.
But if you don't mind, oh mighty warrior Balin, can you catch me some fish for my compost pile?
My garlic business dire meat and some more, well, garlic.
A good healthy compost pile not only provides fertile soil for my garlic to grow faster, but also brings in some worms.
Maybe they'll come in handy very soon.
You know, there's a fish just perfect for composting as it rots really quickly.
Yum!
You can find a picky pike in the greater depths, but only experienced fishermen can reach it.
But the fish seems to be a bit tough.
I recommend you use some potion to restore some stamina.
It's dangerous to go alone, so take this.
Oh, nice.
Good luck, Balin.
Come back when you have the picky pike.
And tell me how the potion tastes.
Okay.
Oh, so Balin...
Wait.
Greg sells potions?
When the fuck did Greg sell potion?
You are a garlic farmer.
Where are you getting these potions?
Wait, what happened to Greg's house?
Um...
An evil Cthulhu guy came over and destroyed everything.
And now the servers are down, so only I can save the world.
Alright.
Maybe it's a garlic potion.
So, like, the only adventurer right now is me because the servers are down.
Wait, there's a chest here.
Alright.
Money!
Ooh!
An EXP orb!
Nice.
I'm level 7 now.
Alright, let's see.
I think it has to be the...
Uh, okay.
That has to be the thing that I'm supposed to catch.
What is he like?
Wait, no.
What?
Is that not him?
Or is it this guy?
Oh, okay.
No, that's the catfish.
Some fish bite into everything and get even without bait.
Okay.
Oh.
Whoops.
I'm...
Oh.
Nice.
Alright.
Okay, nice.
Oh, I'm doing it, guys.
Oh, shit!
I...
Okay.
I was doing it.
I...
Never mind.
Never.
She caught her hope.
Stop.
Okay.
I...
Guys, never hope.
Never hope.
Never st- believe.
Believing is wrong.
Okay.
Now it should be fine.
What the fuck?
Okay.
What?
Never believe, guys.
Believing is a lie.
What the fuck?
That was perfect.
That should have been perfect.
I'm just gonna block right now.
I can't be bothered anymore.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
This is some hardcore fishing in Deltarune, guys.
Oh, my God.
He's almost there.
Oh, nice.
All right.
He only prefers a certain type of bait at a certain time, on a certain day, at a certain temperature.
It's just garlic!
It's literally just garlic!
Like... Believing and hope is alive, they tell you.
Okay.
We need, like, three, right?
We gotta get two more.
I learned that the hard way today during the Summer Game Fest.
I was so happy.
I legitimately thought that, uh...
I thought we were gonna get Nicktoons Unite.
A sequel to Nicktoons Unite.
And then it was just some shitty, uh, fucking, uh, low-budget game.
They killed multiverses for this.
Like...
I was so scared.
I was actually like, no way.
They're actually gonna do a reboot to, uh, catch anything big lately.
Morning!
Morning, Paul!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I lost hype so fucking fast.
I was so sad.
I... Legitimately, they were, like, Nicktoons.
And then, like, Timmy started saying stuff.
And then, like, they included Timmy.
And then, like, you could sort of vaguely see, like, you know, Danny Phantom.
And, uh, Jimmy Neutron.
And it was literally some shh.
And then you hear SpongeBob.
And it's just... It was just some fucking, uh...
I don't even know what game they were doing.
I didn't even... I can't even tell what game it was!
Like, I can't even tell!
Yeah, it was so good back then.
That's why I was so sad.
That's why I was, like, really, really sad that it wasn't what I thought it was.
And look, I can't believe they killed multiverses for that shh.
Okay, nice block.
Holy shh, it was so far in the sea.
I'm not bothering doing perfect parry.
I don't understand.
I don't... I don't understand.
Okay, nice.
Yay, level A!
Alright.
And then the Resident Evil 9 bait.
That was... I can't believe they lie.
I can't believe they would just do that!
Lie on the internet?
In front of hundreds and thousands of people?
Also, I thought it was funny that Splitgate 2 was... became a battle royale.
The pikey... the picky pike!
Thank you so much, Balin!
My garlic will love this!
And when my garlic is happy, I'm happy!
Check back later!
I bet there will be some worms for you and your fishing hook!
But first, as a reward for your good deed, have some garlic for my storage!
Still fresh, I promise!
Please help!
Oh!
Wait, did you hear that?
That screen clearly came from the forest!
Be quick, mighty dragon slayer!
Maybe the guard has seen something!
Oh my god!
The token!
The Amy actress!
Finally!
A woman!
I need your aid!
Just buy... do you wanna help me and my family?
Just buy some of our hands!
Ooh!
I could have a bucket!
Oh my god, guys!
I heard the bucket is a really good exploit!
We gotta get it!
We have... we have to get the bucket!
I heard you can skip all the way to, like, three chapters!
For the peace of the kingdom!
Nice day for fishing, ain't it?
The bucket skipped!
There was a horrible scream coming from the woods!
My sandals could get me over any obstacle in the woods easily, you know?
So I could check out the screams!
But no can do, sir!
I have to protect Honeywood!
What?
You want leisure sandals?
You wanna enter the forest and investigate the screams?
But you're just a lowly background fisherman!
I could give you my precious sandals, but if I can't jump over the scoundrels anymore, I will need to get something to protect myself!
Get me some armor, and I will part with the sandals!
The breastplate of Argon!
A legendary piece of armor!
Should be quite fitting for protecting the peace of the kingdom!
Maybe ask the blacksmith about it!
Alright, I shall ask other you about this!
I shall ask Rowan number two about this!
Hey, Balin!
Balin!
My old pal!
What brings you here in this dire times?
The breastplate of Argon?
Don't know why you need heavy armor to go fishing!
In fact, your class doesn't allow any armor at all!
Whatever that means!
What?
You need it for the guard?
You're gonna wear those stinky sandals just to jump over some stuff?
That's weird!
But you do you, Balin!
Tell you what, Balin!
You definitely earn a reward for whacking that dragon upon!
And I'll totally give you the breastplate of Argon!
Unfortunately, I don't have it anymore!
Remember that angry squid guy?
I could've trashed that piece of seafood myself!
I just didn't want to!
Anyone attacked!
A lot of my stuff was blown into the lake!
You own a fishing rod!
I know how to- Okay, skip!
Skip-a!
Okay, skip-a!
Alright, let's go!
I got enough lore!
I am allowed to skip!
It's part of the story!
Alright!
Skip-a!
Accept!
Guys, I'm allowed to skip!
It's part of the game!
Okay, I assume it's that, right?
Which one am I trying to fish for?
Okay.
Wait!
Yeah!
But he owns three fishing rods!
Oh yeah!
I knew it!
I knew that was- that was it!
Okay!
Alright!
Just don't skip Greg!
As long as I don't skip Greg, it's fine!
Okay!
I found out what I needed to do!
And I was like, skip-a-skip-a!
This is the one game where I'm legally allowed to skip stuff!
Wait!
Is that not it?
What the fuck did I pick up?
Oh!
It was just literally wood!
Okay!
What the fuck?
What is it?
Where is it?
No, I found wood!
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
Okay!
I was not expecting that!
Hahaha!
I forgot that, um, he eats anything!
I was like, my magnet!
Hahaha!
Oh shit!
Okay!
Just- I guess I'll just die!
Sorry!
I- I cannot be bothered!
Hahaha!
Magnetic wood!
Yeah!
I was gonna say!
I found it!
Oh, I see it!
I see it!
It's like, over there!
The glowing thing, right here!
Alright, here you go!
Yeah, I was gonna say!
I was like, what the fuck?
That was my magnet!
He's just very hungry!
He's so hungry!
How are you so hungry?
You have fish everywhere!
Like, are you stupid?
Alright!
Hello, babe!
Uh...
Baradun, I got- I got this!
Oh wait!
Not Baradun!
Sorry!
All your names start with B!
I'm getting confused!
Sorry!
Bog- Bogger!
Balan, my man!
Bogger, sorry!
The one and only breastplate of Argon!
Legendary armor worn by the greatest adventurer!
Um...
If we were all of them as a QA, if functionality exists, it should be exploited, such as...
Zero!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
The finest fighter and noblest kings alike!
The pinnacle of blacksmithing!
No, wait!
This is just some rusty piece of crap!
Actually, give me a few minutes.
I'll try to get rid of the rust, remove some of the dents, and give it a paint job!
Make it nice and shiny again!
Alright.
It's finished!
A unique breastplate of Argon!
Probably the best there is!
See you soon, pal!
Nice!
It was just that easy!
Alright, let's go!
Don't accept his side quest if he's getting his hand!
Okay, but, like, it's free money!
A king and country!
It really exists!
I must say!
I didn't expect you to actually find it!
I guess that means say goodbye to my leisure sandals!
Give me a moment, please!
Alright.
Okay.
I've said farewell to my beloved sandals!
Here you are!
For king and country!
Yay!
I can finally jump now!
Go, Balen!
Go!
You can now parkour!
Oh, shit!
Wait, I am actually trying to parkour!
Okay!
Hahaha!
Alright, I didn't actually think I had to parkour!
That was just a joke!
But, okay!
Also, I thought it was funny!
People were, like, really mad about the fact that Square Enix, um, made a- Wait, what the fuck?
Square Enix made a, uh, Trouble in Terrace Town game for the release- For, like, the release of- for the Summer Game Fest release.
Well, back to it!
Oh my god!
Rowan number four!
Is it just all Rowan?
Haha!
I don't think I've seen you before!
I'm the woodcutter!
My wife and child need some wood to keep us warm in these cold winter nights, and- Wait!
You're a fisherman!
No fish here!
I can tell you that!
Only big old trees, and that unclimbable cliff over there!
I suppose I could tuck down some trees to build a way up of that cliff if you're interested!
But I don't think my brittle hatchet is up to this enormous task!
Nice day for fishing, ain't it?
Yesterday, or was it a few years ago?
Anyway, at some point, an adventurer came by and told me about her quest for the Gilded Axe, with a fabulous edge that needs to be sharpened!
Bring me this wondrous Gilded Axe, and I'll gladly use it to build a path up for you!
The good townspeople of Honeywood might know about it!
Alright!
Time to go back!
Hahaha!
Alright!
Oh my god!
All that parkour for nothing!
Alright, let's see...
Where is he?
Where...
Who has...
Oh, Fred knows where it is!
Alright, Fred!
I know something that smells fishy!
You know, because of all the fish!
Sorry, dumb joke!
Thankfully, you're a man of humor and forgiveness!
But I should make up for my insult though!
You're looking for the Gilded Axe?
Eh?
Well, let me tell you a story about the adventure and the artifacts of ancient legends!
I was swimming in the Greater Deaths recently, and took a dive a bit too far out.
My wife, Freda, heard much about it.
It made her sick would worry.
She lives me a s- Oh wait!
There's another woman?!
A baby wearing a costume of a sad old man!
Don't listen to him!
Fred can tie a rock around his neck and swim in the ocean for all I care!
Anyway, I saw a strange glimmer underwater.
An axe, a golden one, lying on the ground.
I am no dwarf, so I saw no use for it.
Ah yes!
A golden axe!
What possible use could we have for gold?!
As usual, if there's any chance to become financially stable, you can be sure Fred won't take it!
Fred is so moe!
Hahaha!
Wait, did you ever think that maybe an axe is too heavy for an older fruit merchant to live from underwater?
Wait, he's not even a fruit merchant!
He sells fish!
Sorry, excuse me.
The axe may be the thing you're looking for, Balin.
I heard you're doing quests now.
He's such a- she's such a hater!
She doesn't believe in him!
I can't believe it!
Why won't you believe in him?
He's doing his best trying to provide!
Look at him!
He doesn't even have a home anymore!
Fred is a nice guy.
He's just trying to do his best.
Alright, oh I can run while on my ship.
Wait, where would the axe be?
I'm scared of the- I'm scared of the fucking catfish.
Okay, get the gilded axe.
Okay.
What could it be?
What the fuck?
Okay, it's not here.
Oh, it's over here!
Wait, how the fuck do I get that?
Wait, what?
It's over there!
How do you get that?
I think there's something I can- Maybe- Oh wait, I can wear a hat!
Oh wait, that is my hat!
Wait, that's the- Uh...
Okay, let's see if there's like anything- If like they have anything that I can use for it.
Oh yeah!
Your potion work!
Okay, he doesn't care about that.
Huh?
Okay...
I need to figure out how to- Get that fish- Or get that axe.
Okay, it should be here, right?
Whoops.
Okay, it's- It's here.
Alright.
Okay, whoops.
Okay.
It's here.
Oh.
Oh, I can cancel fishing.
Okay.
Wait, but how do I- How do I get that?
What the fuck?
How do I get that?
What?
Okay, I cancel the fishing.
Okay.
Listen carefully.
My voice isn't what it once was.
Oh!
Hello?
Hello, brave fisherman.
I am called Thidan.
Mighty light god of the seas.
I can- Bend the line.
Bend the bullet.
I can help you save Azerim.
Seek out my shrine at the beach.
So we can have a little chat.
I'll wait for you.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna have special powers.
Don't worry.
I'm heading over.
Wait.
Don't- Don't move so fast.
Yeah, that's just CGI.
Wait, is that another?
Oh!
Oh, there's more bait.
What's this?
Palm nut.
Oh, it's more bait!
Yeah, cause one of the fishes like palm nut.
Oh!
There you are.
How do you do, young buck?
Don't avert your eyes, freshman.
It is I, Thidan, the light god of the seas.
What?
No.
I won't punish you for catching fish.
Quite the opposite.
I'm more like one of the old gods, you know?
I need sacrifices to restore my strength.
Fish sacrifices.
Which means- Oh, he wants a virgin fish.
Which means a fishman like you would be my perfect champion.
I know you would understand, dear Yoinker.
Just like I understand you and your problem.
You're on a quest.
But current underwaters are finicky and out of your control.
As in- What?
He's an ancient god.
Don't- All gods, all they want is just a virgin of their kind.
And since he's a fish god, he would want a virgin fish.
That you throw into the volcano.
I, who can change water streams.
But first, I will need some proof.
Proof that you are worthy, kiddo.
The lake near the town Honeywood is filled with delicious fish.
Catch at least one of each kind.
And sacrifice them at the statue of my refreshing likeness.
Each sacrifice will make me stronger.
And in return, I will be able to increase your power as well.
But first things first.
Uh, Belargus, thank you for the super shot.
Thank you, thank you.
If you do as a command, I can and will redirect the water streams.
No, it's just easy.
I'll just sacrifice the children.
This way, you'll reach the object you desire.
And you can continue your epic quest.
A piece of old wisdom.
Uh, there's the- Okay, they lay so many eggs.
What's one child fish gonna do?
How does that- Cuz they lay hundreds- Why do you think some animals lay hundreds of eggs?
It's because they knew to- They knew that some of them aren't gonna survive.
Why do you think, um, those like sea turtles fucking lay eggs in the- Um, on the beach, lay like 50 plus eggs on the beach and go, peace.
See ya.
And then like, when the student- The moment they hatch, literally everyone wants to eat them.
Because they're like, you know, only 1% of you guys are gonna live.
So like- It's just pure statistics.
Lord Curtis says thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes, turtles are literally born in D-Day.
They-they-they hatch, they come out of the sand, and it's D-Day.
You'll need palm knights as bait to catch some of the fish in the shallow water.
It'll surprise you, but you can find them here at the palm trees.
Don't take too long, young champion.
My age may be plenty, but the patience of my bladder, you know?
Alright, let's grab more of these.
Alright, let's go over there and sacrifice our fish.
Okay, and then- Oh, okay, so that's how I change my bait.
So the more children an animal can make, the less chance they'll survive.
Oh my god, I have to get all of that?
Okay, that's fine.
They have the baby ones, okay.
Alright.
This is why they're endangered.
Look, they don't have the cute tacks like pandas.
They're not as lucky as pandas.
Literally, pandas...
Okay, I'm gonna say it.
But like, if it wasn't for human intervention, pandas would be like long gone.
Like...
What about rats?
Rats are...
Okay, do you know rats...
The survivability for rats in the wild?
It is not that much, guys.
The survivability of rats in the wild is very, very low.
There is a rat out there that...
There's a rat out there in the wild where...
Um...
I don't know if you guys know this, but like...
It...
When it's time to bang, they literally bang until they get a heart attack and die.
For the...
For the survival of their species.
All right.
Yeah, literally death by snooze dude.
The tree!
Like...
You're like, God, I wish that was me.
All right.
Here, here.
No, there's actually a...
A type of cat species.
Um...
Where...
Where like...
It's like, the moment it's time, he just goes everywhere.
Travel around the world.
Travel around the plains to be like, gotta find as many as possible.
And then he dies of a heart attack.
To ensure the survival of...
What was it?
He needs to continue the bloodline.
He's just trying to continue the bloodline.
All right.
We need...
Honeywood and the snakefish.
Okay.
That's just this.
Survival of the freakiest.
Exactly.
Okay.
This guy.
I hate this guy.
This guy is way too strong.
All right.
I'm not even gonna try parry.
I'll do parry for the bosses.
But these guys are fucking crazy.
Oh my God.
I was not paying attention.
I'm sorry.
I don't read sometimes.
Not heart attack.
It dies of muscle digger due to much freak...
There's one that actually dies of a heart attack.
I remember because I watched a documentary about it.
About...
Okay.
I don't remember what the documentary was really about.
I just remember...
I was...
It was like late at night.
It was on the National Geographic channel.
It was on the National Geographic channel at my grandparents' place.
And then like...
I was like up in their room...
Up in their bedroom.
And I was like...
Woo!
Look at this lovely nature documentary.
I said as I was like...
I don't know...
11 years old.
And then that like stuck with me.
I don't know why...
Like...
Out of everything...
That fun fact stuck with me for my whole life.
Like I...
I like remember that shit.
For the rest of my life.
You're back from Honeywood Lake?
Not with empty hands.
Honeywood Heron...
Uh...
Gurdon...
Gooper...
And even some...
Snakefish.
You're indeed a worthy fisherman, my dear.
Indeed, and cunning as you are...
You probably already guessed that the dark lord he's held in...
The menace you faced earlier...
Is of my own blood.
If gods have blood, that is.
I can't deny it any longer.
Yeez is right into the core.
And we need to stop him.
He was always a bit unbridled.
But somehow, he's now out of his mind like a fish out of water.
Thus, I am inclined to help you, champion of Thaedon.
Light god of the seas.
Let me...
Uh...
Let me invoke all of my current power to activate the water streams.
This way, you will fulfill your quest to recover the gilded axe you're looking for.
Oh nice, I have a new magic power.
Alright.
Oh no, he's just moving it closer.
Oh!
Now it has like little things.
I already told you this.
I think...
But as your gods...
Oh my god, okay.
And then...
I felt like I was living a lie, watching all these nature documentaries.
Because the majority of those nature documentary films were filmed without sound.
And then...
They add the sound...
Post...
Like...
Post-production.
Because a lot of them were recorded without sound.
I...
And then like...
I felt like I was living a fucking lie.
And I already told you this.
I think...
But as your guide...
And...
Sponsor...
I am now able to increase your power.
Which you would very much need, my dear tadpole.
Sacrifice more fish to me.
So like...
You would hear them like...
Hear like these like...
Sound effects of like...
You know...
Of them like walking around...
Crawling...
Or like...
Um...
Yeah, I know.
It's hard to really get a boom...
You know...
You stick a boom mic in front of a fucking lion.
Like...
Can you imagine that?
You know like those...
Hidden animal cameras.
And then you put out...
You attach a fucking giant ass mic...
Like on the...
Hidden camera.
And...
Like...
What did they say?
But like...
A lot of sounds you hear...
From nature documentaries...
Or nature shows...
Are like...
Post-production...
Or like...
And they're like...
Fake...
Basically.
Yeah...
You can put a mic up to a fucking bug...
And be like...
Alright...
What do the bug...
Hello...
We're gonna interview you.
Oh yeah...
You attach a microphone on a drone...
And you just...
Fly closer...
Sacrifice more fish to me...
At least one of each region...
For I will enhance your spells...
Now...
No need to bow...
Bow low...
It's bad for your back...
I can tell...
Don't forget to use the currents...
Okay, nice...
Oh, it's like a little collection thing...
Pulls...
To inflict more damage...
Okay, cool...
Yeah...
Those folly artists can't keep...
I didn't know...
Okay, when I...
Okay, when I found that out...
I felt like...
I've been living a fucking lie...
I'll be like...
Oh, so that's what...
So that's what ants sound like...
But no...
Stupid me for thinking there was a fucking microphone attached to that camera...
I don't know...
Like...
I don't know why I thought there was a fucking giant camera...
Fucking attached to the ground...
I...
Oh shit...
No, wait...
L...
LT...
Swap spells...
Nah...
I don't want fishing...
Get out of here...
I'm trying to...
Catch that stupid...
Oh wait...
Try to catch that stupid thing...
What are your opinion?
But crocodiles...
Rawr...
Alright...
Okay, I got wood...
Nice...
Okay...
Oh, and then...
I love like...
When they do those like...
You know when they do those like...
Hidden...
Um...
Those like...
Hidden cameras...
Where they...
Make like a fake penguin or whatever...
Like...
A fake animal or whatever...
And be like...
I...
I love...
Oh shit...
Oh, I just need to be a little bit...
Can I...
Do it from here?
Okay, nice...
No!
Are you serious?
Okay...
Alright, nice...
I got it...
I love like the...
Uh...
Where they make like...
Actual fake ass...
Machines or whatever...
To spy cams...
To...
Like...
Spy on the animals...
Yeah, but you could tell...
Like...
There's one with poop too...
Where they made a fake...
Like...
Elephant poop to use to spy on people...
Or...
Sorry...
Spy on the animals...
Not people...
Cause then like...
You know...
Ethically...
That's wrong...
But we can do it on the animals...
Cause they don't know better...
Like...
Ah...
So you really retrieved the axe...
Baton...
I'm astonished...
See how it goes...
Even someone who was just a stick...
And a piece of string could do it...
Fred...
Proven once again...
You're the laziest bum in town...
Oh...
My dear wife...
Use your eyes for once...
The axe isn't even complete...
The handle is missing...
It's worthless...
I would have risked my life for nothing...
Huh...
Worthless is a strong word...
For a fruit merchant...
Who hasn't sold a single piece of fruit...
For months...
And the head of golden axe...
Is still...
The head of a golden axe...
Genius...
My bet is that...
Bolder...
Honeywood's...
Muscular...
Handsome...
Successful...
Blacksmith...
Who isn't a sluggish fruit merchant...
Would have no problem fixing it...
Aw...
Poor Fred...
Guys...
I...
Aw...
Fred needs someone new...
Pralyn doesn't need to hear you...
Whispering all those sweet nothings...
Praying that snobbish boger of visiting...
Showing him...
The axe might be a good idea though...
Also...
Here's a little word for proving...
I didn't imagine the axe under water...
Spend it...
Well...
Perhaps for some fruits...
From a humble poor fruit merchant...
Bro you don't even sell fruits...
I'm literally...
I'm just selling the fish I fucking caught...
Alright...
Bogan...
Baelin...
Alright Bogan...
Rowan number two...
My man...
Back again...
Engracing me with his presence...
What is it you're holding there?
Nice day for fishing...
Ain't it?
The head of the gilded axe...
Not bad...
But without a proper handle...
You can't do much with it...
Good news for the trees out there...
Ha ha ha...
Tell you what...
I'm in a good mood...
And I know exactly what we need for the handle...
Some steel...
And some leather...
Both might actually be up your water...
That way...
Watery Alley...
First...
The leather you can get from any dark wood digger at the beach...
I was expecting a shipment of the steel a while ago...
And well...
The ship sunk in the recent storm...
Should be lying on the coral gardens ground now...
Guess the gods have a dumb sense of humor...
So...
There you have it...
The coral's garden in the far west...
At the coast of Azerim...
Bring me some dark wood leather...
And steel...
And I'll help you fix the gilded axe...
Maybe you get the steel with some magnet thing...
But I'm not egghead...
Like Baron...
Alright...
Let's go grab...
Is this just fetch quests?
That's very...
Viva la dirt league of them...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha...
What was that short?
Where like...
Um...
Uh...
Where they were like...
You know like...
Um...
Where...
They would pad...
They just like did fetch quests all of...
All the time...
Alright...
Here we go...
Wait...
How do I get my boat?
Oh wait...
I do this...
Okay...
I was like so confused...
I can basically...
Alright...
I was gonna say...
How do I...
Fucking...
Catch this...
Okay...
What does he want?
Alright...
Do you like garlic?
Are you a garlic fish?
Hello...
Alright...
LT...
The swap spells...
Okay...
What do I do to it?
Oh shit...
That's what I do to it...
Okay...
That's right...
I use all my magic...
Oh...
Alright...
Defending...
Oh shit...
I keep forgetting to read...
I keep thinking he's like ready...
Okay...
No...
Oh my god...
That was like...
So much...
Okay...
Don't worry...
Oh...
I'm worrying...
Nevermind...
Okay...
Don't worry...
There we go...
Okay...
We got one of them...
We need three?
Okay...
That's five...
Wee...
Don't worry...
I'm...
Don't worry guys...
Don't worry...
I definitely know what I'm doing...
Okay...
Send him all the way here...
And then...
Oh my god...
It's still...
Okay...
That did a lot too...
That's good...
I'm just gonna hold it...
Oh...
Blocking...
Never punished...
That's right...
Okay...
I'm just gonna hold it...
Nice...
Alright...
We need one more...
Please...
Let me save the woman!
All I wanna do is just save the woman!
I'm...
I swear to god...
It's been so long...
I feel like they told me about the woman and then like...
Nothing ever happened...
Okay...
Nice...
Why save the woman instead of fishing?
You're right...
Balen wouldn't...
Balen wouldn't want that...
All Balen wants to do is fish...
Okay...
That should be the seal I need...
I need five...
Oh wait...
It's all here...
It's literally all here...
Okay...
Let's grab some more nuts just in case...
I have three...
Oh fuck...
The woman can wait...
This is much more important...
Okay...
Nice...
Okay nice...
I got all five...
Yeah...
Alright...
Time to talk to Bulger...
I am...
I'm grabbing more nuts...
Fish more important...
Doki...
How dare you...
Balen has no time for women...
He needs a fish...
Every day is a nice day for fishing...
Alright...
Let's go back...
Teach men...
Women starve...
Fish...
Hungry...
Not...
Lifetime...
One...
Alright...
There's some very strong steel...
And the smoothest litter I've ever laid my eyes on...
Of course...
I'll keep some for myself...
I'm not an adventurer...
Thus...
My work isn't free...
Still...
This is more than enough to forge a nice handle for your gilded axe...
Yay...
Here...
I can glue this together...
Alright...
But to make it actually work...
Yay...
I glued it together...
See...
I was just visiting...
Greg...
To tell him how better my quest art than this...
And my return...
Okay...
Alright...
Time to get the hammer guys...
I wonder where his hammer is...
Oh...
My...
God...
His grandfather's hammer that he'll...
For sure...
Never lose...
There we go...
Wow...
Can't believe I got it...
Here you go...
Booger...
Hey Balen...
By the gods...
You found my grandfather's hammer...
My hammer...
I gotta do my dailies...
Give me a sec guys...
Gotta do my dailies...
Just how much this hammer is rightfully mine...
Not my brother's...
I vow...
Never lose it again...
And you brought the parts with the gilded axe too...
With my hammer...
Everything's ready...
It's finished...
Here you are pal...
The gilded axe in its full glory...
Now go hack some fishers or something...
Alright...
Time to...
Finally...
Is it time?
Can I finally save the woman?
Alright...
Time to re...
Meet...
Where...
It's time to meet...
Uh...
Rowan 4...
Again...
Okay...
Wait...
I have to parkour...
It's actual parkour...
Alright...
Rowan 4...
These trees ain't gonna chop themselves down...
Look at that colour...
I love it...
With this fine tool...
Cutting those big trees should be no problem...
Wait here for an hour or so...
Just need a short breather...
Alright...
Sorry...
They ran out of budget to animate this part...
Um...
Pixel animation is very hard guys...
Uh...
Just like...
Um...
In the world of Azrim...
When they had to cut the CGI...
Quite the work that was...
But look at the gilded axe...
Not a single scratch...
And me neither...
Which is a welcome change...
The way up the hill is ready...
Be careful though...
My nose is telling me it won't be the safest place...
At least not the place with the nicest smell...
Thanks again for the axe...
I don't need to cut down one more tree...
So I can sell the wood...
But you can have some as a reward...
My wife and child will be warm on this winter night...
Alright...
Nice...
Parkour...
Woah...
I'm the best...
I sense that you're approaching dangerous territory...
Orcs of Swarmogara are overhead...
They are known to be quite hostile...
Um...
And currently...
They have several travelers in their clutches...
It would be a bad idea could go near them...
As you're not a mighty high sorcerer like myself...
But it doesn't seem you're level up enough for fighting orcs...
Unfortunately...
I have important manners to ponder...
And can't take care of the orcs...
You should consult the townsfolk at Honeywood...
To see if anyone has...
Oh my...
I'm dropping down...
Oh, I can't...
There's an invisible...
I'm dropping down...
You don't...
Oh, I can't...
Aww...
No...
I have to go back to Honeywood?
Oh my god...
I just want to save the woman!
I...
Oh my god...
Oh, friend...
What...
Okay, you know what?
Fuck this...
Alright...
How much is the hat?
How much...
Okay...
Alright...
Fuck this...
I'm selling my...
Fish...
Okay...
Skipa skipa skipper...
Skip skip...
Skip...
Alright...
I'm selling stuff...
Skip Skip Skip Skip...
Okay...
Finally...
Alright...
The wooden bucket...
Yes...
Alright...
There you go...
Now I should be able to...
Oh, I have the worms!
Nice.
There are so many worms.
They escaped and are probably wobbling all over Azrim.
That could be useful.
Just pick them up and- Oh wait, what the fuck?
Holy shit.
Oh my god, look at these worms.
They look like the worms from the WMD.
Finally, I skipped this part of the game.
Yay, garlic.
They look familiar.
Yeah, they look very familiar.
Yeah, worms from worms.
Yeah, they look like worms from- Yeah.
Alright guys, I'm gonna call it here.
Alright, honest opinion.
I think there is definitely- Oh, get the rose brace.
There is definitely- I think this game is about fetch quests, basically.
And like, sometimes I just want a fish.
I just-
I want a- I want a fish, you know?
And I'm like, I'm tired of fetching quests.
Yeah.
Uh, I think- Okay, it is a chill game.
It's very chill.
Um, it's a very chill game.
Um, I don't know if I can say this is a stream game.
I can see myself play- Oh wait, the nice worms.
I see myself playing this to pass the time to just relax and chill.
Um, I- I feel like this game also- Um, it is a- I think if you like Viva- Viva La Dirt League, you'll like this game.
Because they have a lot of- a lot of really good inside jokes.
Like, if you like inside jokes- Oh hey, worms.
Nice.
There's a lot of inside jokes that people who like the YouTube channel- Um, Viva La Dirt League would definitely enjoy a lot.
Yeah, it's definitely a Zatsudon game.
So if I'm like doing super chat reading, there's a lot of like Easter eggs to the story.
And like a lot of references and everything.
Um, so I feel like if you don't watch your channel, you might not be like as into the game as I am right now.
Because there's a lot of funny jokes that I know from the videos themselves.
Um, yeah.
I just want fish and safe women.
Like that's all I want to do.
I don't want to do your stupid quest, Greg.
I hate your quest, Greg.
Uh, I hate your quest too.
I- Um, but, uh... I definitely- I think it's fun.
I think it's fun, but I can tell that this is definitely not like really, eh- Uh, I didn't even save the- Well, it's TOO BAD!
They keep making me go back and forth.
It's TOO BAD!
I guess we will never save the woman.
I guess we'll never save her, guys.
That's too bad.
She'll be stuck there forever.
We don't need a saver.
I just want a fish and I got my bucket.
That's all I need.
I got fish and I got bucket.
It's always a nice day for fishing.
Let me do one more fish.
Oh, okay.
He doesn't like that.
Okay.
Does anybody like anything?
Yeah.
Not everybody gets a happy end name.
She'll just die, I guess.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's at least be able to catch one fish.
Yeah.
Yeah, Tenjin.
It's a nice day for fishing, ain't it?
But it was fun, though.
I had a great time.
I had a great time trying this game out.
But that's my honest review of this game.
I feel like it's more so of like, you know, just a chatting game to hang out with chat.
Like a super chat.
Maybe if I do like super chat reading, which has been like years since I've done a super chat reading.
I could obviously play this game while I'm reading super chats.
I just all I have to do is just skip the dialogue and just start fishing.
But it's very relaxing game.
I won't say it's a streaming game.
That's what I'll say.
Like in my honest opinion, this game isn't really much of a...
isn't much of a streaming game.
Um, but it's more so of like just a hangout chatting game.
Um, and but they do have a lot of inside references.
Like I like that a lot of you guys also like, you know, watch the same channel as me.
So we all like understood the references.
Um, and uh, and uh, all the like all the, uh, you know, all the little things that they put in their videos that we recognize.
Uh, in like in the game itself.
So yeah, I do appreciate that.
It was nice.
It was a really nice effort.
There's a lot.
I think it definitely was more so a fetch quest.
But I had a great time.
I had a great time.
Um, it's called Viva La Dirt League.
I highly suggest checking the channel out.
It's really, they do some really fun skits.
I love their skits and everything.
And their favorite, my favorite series is, um, the Epic NPC Man.
And, um, what was the other one that I said?
It was Epic NPC Man and the, uh, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Sorry.
I had a very long day.
Today.
It started at like 8 a.m.
So.
And the Blizzard one.
The Blizzard parody.
Um, so the Epic NPC, Epic NPC series is basically like a parody of World of Warcraft.
And then, um, and then they made a parody of the developers of the Epic NPC Man Adventures.
Which is like a parody of Blizzard.
And so like, it's like very similar.
Um, so yeah.
I had a great time.
Anyway, guys.
Tomorrow I'll be back home.
Um, so I'll have my actual setup.
And then it'll be back to normal again.
Um, next week there's a lot of stuff to look forward to.
We have a sponsor.
We have a collab next week.
I won't say who yet.
Um, because we're so... I forgot what time... We didn't plan out a time yet.
So I don't want to promise anything.
Um, since there's no...
The time hasn't been finalized.
Uh, but it'll be a fun collab.
Um, but yes.
Um, I'm happy to be back home, uh, tomorrow.
Um, and you know, go back to the routine and everything.
I hope you guys still like all these streams.
All these normal, like, random streams in between.
With the watch-alongs.
Uh, it sucks that they had the watch...
Oh man, the timing was so bad for me.
You know, having the... the game trailer previews when I'm traveling.
Ah!
My god.
I hate that.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
You know.
I mean, nice to have watched it, you know, on my actual setup.
But, uh, but it was still really fun.
I had a great time watching.
Uh...
Watching...
Watching it all.
Anyway.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Uh...
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you...
Stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause...
You deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!